pauline raguenet de saint-albain 25
foucault à connaître cet album j'ai 31
ans
moi je suis qui n'est donc c'est
beaucoup plus facile de trouver je suis
ébéniste
et avec plus d espace de notre rythme
c'est agréable de se sentir accueilli
sentir que ils sont contents de voir qui
est des jeunes qui cherchent à
s'installer et à travailler dans la
région
déjà parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens
d'habiter paris en fait
enfin avec un atelier slam et parce
qu'on a envie de vivre un peu plus
lentement
comme c'est une région que c'est
magnifique c'est assez encourageant
couple
là on sache vraiment une maison de
activement évidemment on cherche une
maison avec un atelier attenant quoi ou
du moins pendant tout près pour que ce
soit plus sympa d'aller bosser à pied ou
en vélo on aimerait beaucoup être partie
plus possible
je
on a tout à apprendre parce qu'on est
quand même les citadins j'irai notre
peur c'est d'être un peu tout seul dans
la campagne
et un peu isolé parce que déjà on n'est
pas habitué à vivre à la campagne et
puis je pense que c'est bon personne
d'être isolé ce matin n'avaient pas de
passé la nuit dans la campagne
[Rires]
ça m'inquiète pas de m'éloigner de la
région parisienne fait il s'agit juste
poursuivre mon activité avec la même
clientèle
mais voilà après je ne sais pas du tout
quel est le potentiel
vis-à-vis de mon activité la dent dans
le morvan
finalement même dans une grande ville on
peut être super isolée à l'est
supermarché acheter des trucs qu'on ne
sait pas d'où ils viennent
enfin je le fait de savoir d'où viennent
ces aliments c'est déjà de la relation
martin-pêcheur magnifique on a un peu
fait ça pour un confinement aussi on a
un peu découvert le potager la jouette
qui dira c'est thomas tu sais c'est naïf
en mai et on est encore des naïfs mais
c'est aussi ça qui nous attire à la
campagne